HE SCORED 25 OFF THE BENCH LAST
NIGHT, GOT THE WORD TODAY.
>> SIX, SIX, SIX, SIX, SIX.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> BEFORE WE GET INTO THE TEAM,
TODAY'S NBA, HONESTLY, YOU CAN
BE A STARTER OFF THE BENCH IF
YOU SEE THE BIG PICTURE.
TO HAVE A YOUNG PLAYER TRUST IN
WHAT I SAY, TRUST IN WHAT WE
SAY, THAT'S BIG.
THEY HAVE THEIR OWN VISION.
ALSO, BEING A FATHER, IMAGINE
BEING A FATHER, BEING AN NBA
PLAYER, SIXTH MAN OF THE YEAR
AND GIVING US WHAT WE ASK FROM
YOU, THAT'S A LOT.
THAT'S BIG.
TOOK A LOT OF STEPS THIS YEAR.
IT'S BIGGER THAN SIXTH MAN OF
THE YEAR FOR YOU.
TOOK A LOT OF STEPS BEING A MAN,
BEING A PROFESSIONAL.
I'M PROUD OF YOU.
>> WE KNEW IT WAS COMING.
>> CHAMPIONSHIP ON THREE.
ONE, TWO, THREE, CHAMPIONSHIP.
>> I MIGHT NOT EVER SEE ONE OF
THESE.
>> WE NEVER HAD NOBODY WIN THIS.
THE FIRST TIME.
>> WE DON'T HAVE ONE OF THES